and we're gonna begin with this an
administrator at Morehouse College has
been put on leave after a former
students accusations of sexual
misconduct Michael key posted a video on
Twitter last week about the alleged
conduct of assistant dean an interim
student housing director - Marcus Cruz
at least two more students have come
forward with allegations against faculty
members which they say the school also
ignored
mark Strassmann is at the all-male
College in Atlanta mark you spoke to one
of the accusers what did he tell you
here's the deal Tony his name is Michael
key he says he took his frustrations and
allegations to social media because
Morehouse refused to deal with them and
now he says his goal is to make sure
that all schools protect their students
he always targets freshmen and I see it
every day it just sickens me Michael key
says during his freshman year Morehouse
College assistant dean de Marquez Cruz
repeatedly hit on him my freshman year
he used to do such as like hugging me
pinching on my shoes he complained to
Morehouse and says nothing was done
Morehouse has a problem definitely
there's definitely a problem definitely
what is that 100%
um predatorial behavior and it's adults
on students on students yes
another student retweeted keys post last
week and shared a video saying cruz had
also targeted him I didn't feel
comfortable in Morehouse Morehouse is
now investigating the sexual misconduct
allegations and its place crews on
unpaid administrative leave but kee says
the college ignored his complaint until
his tweet went viral in January 2018 he
filed a Title 9 complaint through the
Department of Education the federal law
protects students against sexual
harassment nothing happened for a year
and a half a year and a half it was a
terrible terrible year and a half I
didn't know what to do at that point I
was just following a system I thought
title nine it was gonna be there for me
so I went into deep depression grades
started falling you continue to run into
Cruz I saw him every day all day every
day he's our campus
another former Moorehouse student has
sued the college and several staff
members he asked us to conceal his
identity he claims former assistant
professor Robert Peterson physically and
sexually assaulted him in 2015 while
studying abroad in Brazil he's gripped
my thigh and moved his hands towards my
leg and up towards my private area close
and in Brazil he had like try to like
manhandled me although in a statement of
CBS news
Peterson call the allegations false and
exaggerated and said none of this
happened we need to get rid of the
facade we need to tell people what's
really going on because that's the only
way that this school will be the best it
can be
he has now left Morehouse and is looking
for a new school we got a statement from
Morehouse it said that the school is
committed to providing a safe
environment free from sexual misconduct
and discrimination will investigate and
respond swiftly as for crews Gail
he never got back to us right I'm sure a
Morehouse is listening with both ears
now if they weren't before thank you
very much mark